للوهلة الأولى ، قد تعتقد أن
هذه كانت صورًا ، لكن هذه
رسومات بالقلم الرصاص جزءًا من حركة فنية متنامية
تسمى الواقعية المفرطة عندما
ينظر الناس إلى رسوماتي ،
أود أن يشعروا بإحساس
بالواقع ، فأنت تعلم أن هذه هي أعمالي التي
أحملها  الناس على الأرض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسمي إيرينا ستانلي وأنا
فنان شديد الواقعية ، الواقعية المفرطة
هي مجلة الفن التي تتضمن
رسم رسومات أو لوحات تبدو
واقعية جدًا ولا يمكنك
تمييزها فعليًا عن صورة أو
الواقع لقد بدأت الرسم عندما كان عمري 6
سنوات ، كان والدي مصنعًا للورق ،
لقد نشأت بشكل أساسي حول الكثير من
الورق عندما يرى الناس أعمالي
، عادة ما تكون لقطات ليست
صورة يعجبون بها ، يا إلهي ، إنها ليست صورة
قمت بعملها  أنه بقلم رصاص وأنا
أحب ذلك ، عادةً ما تستغرق أعمالي الكثير من
الوقت لإنشائها أحيانًا يمكنني عمل
قطعة لمدة شهر تقريبًا في بعض الأحيان
قد تصل إلى شهرين اعتمادًا
على مزاجي وحجم  قطعة أحب
[موسيقى
] استخدام أعمالي للتحدث عن القضايا
التي تؤثر على مجتمعي هنا في نيجيريا
، وإفريقيا كلها هي الصوت الذي أملكه
من خلال أعمالي الفنية للتحدث نيابة عن الأشخاص
الذين يمكنهم التحدث عن أنفسهم ،
هذا الشخص غارق تمامًا في النفط
هذا يشير إلى مقدار استخدامنا للنفط
وتدمير مجتمعنا ، وهذا يدل على أننا
لا نرى شرًا ولا يسمع شرًا ولا يتكلم أي
شر
، فأنا أشجع الناس على
التراجع ومحاولة محاكاة الطفولة في
محاولة جعل الناس يتخلفون عن
السداد عندما  التقط قلم الرصاص الخاص بي
وضعه على الورق ، فهو يأخذني بعيدًا ، وهو
شيء لا يمكنني شرحه
[موسيقى]